COMMANDS WE WILL COME TO ORDER.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING TODAY
REMOTELY OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY ARE SENATOR
PORCHES. GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR BORCHERS AND SENATOR
MELENDEZ IS SENATOR MELINDA IS
NOT AN ISSUE GOOD AFTERNOON ALL
RIGHT. WELCOME IF YOU ARE IF
YOU HAVE STAFF ASSISTING YOU
TODAY WOULD YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY
THEM. DO YOU HAVE STAFF WITH
YOU SENATOR BOARD JUST. NOW
SENATOR MELINDA CENTER BORDER
TIONAL STAFF. THE STAFF THANK
YOU A CENTER MELINDA'S DO YOU
HAVE ANY STAFF WITH YOU. NO I
DON'T IT'S JUST A FORMALITY
HAVE TO ASK THE QUESTION ALL
RIGHT. SO WE'RE GLAD TO SEE YOU
HERE AND- SENATORS AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY.
OF THAT NASTY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
I ASKED THAT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED- THAT YOU
RAISE YOUR HAND. FEATURE THAT
FEATURE THAT IS ON YOUR
COMPUTER EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING AND MAKE
SURE WE CAN SEE YOU ON THE
SCREEN AS WELL. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE AGAIN THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN. THEN THE PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU
ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
TO THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALL WHILE. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THEN THE ACCESS CODE IS.
NINE SEVEN NINE SIX ONE FOUR
ONE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE. AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND PLEASE
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
PLEASE BE PATIENT ONCE RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER HE WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
AND READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE ROOM REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LATIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING. TO THE NEW USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ONE BUILT ON TODAY'S AGENDA IT
IS AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU IT WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR COUPLE YET
ALL BUT BEFORE WE HEAR THAT
BILL LET'S PLEASE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BANNON CONSULTANT WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A
SENATOR PLEASE SENATORS PLEASE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON WE
WILL NOW ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE.
BURGESS PRESIDENT. WHAT IS
PRESENT DATA SO YOUR DATA SO
HERE. GONZALEZ PRESIDENT
GONZALEZ PRESIDENT MELENDEZ.
PRESIDENT MELINDA'S PRESENT
MONNING HERE MONNING HERE STERN.
UMBERG AMBERG HERE MY CASKEY
HERE LIKE HUSKY HERE SENATOR
JACKSON YOU HAVE AT LEAST FIVE
MEMBERS PRESENT IN THE CHAMBER
VERY GOOD THANK YOU AND BEFORE
WE START I ALSO WANT TO NOTE-
THE CHEST PASSING OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE TOM BERRYHILL WHO
JUST PASSED AWAY- A GOOD GUY
DID TEND TO US SOMEONE WILL
RESPECTED IN OUR HOUSE. AND SO
OUR CONDOLENCES PLEASED TO HIS
FAMILY- WE HAVE LOST A GOOD
FRIEND CAN UNDERSTAND WE'RE
GOING TO MEMORIALIZE SOME ON
THE FLOOR TODAY- EXCELLENT AND
WE WILL BE MEMORIALIZING HIM ON
THE FLOOR TOMORROW. WITH THAT
LET US GO AHEAD. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED AND- LET US
PROCEED THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIS AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU REGARDING
TENDENCIES SENATOR CAFIERO YOU
MAY PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I GUESS TODAY I DREW
THE SHORT STRAW SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOO
MANY GLEAM ON. MYSELF AND
SENATOR STEVEN BRADFORD- THIS
IS AN ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
MEASURE THAT MUST BE PASSED
BEFORE WE RECESS I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WHO CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS BILL INCLUDING- THE
NUMEROUS TENET ADVOCATES LABOR
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION THE
BANKING COMMUNITIES- OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND OF
COURSE THE CAUGHT MY COLLEAGUES
IN BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS YOU ALL KNOW IN
LESS THAN ONE WEEK THE
CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
EMERGENCY RULE NUMBER ONE WILL
BE RESCINDED AND TENANTS ACROSS
THE STATE WILL BE AT RISK OF
EVICTION FOR NON PAYMENT. OF
RENT. WE MUST ACT NOW TO
ESTABLISH NEW ADDICTION
PROTECTION TONIGHT I KNOW THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HEARD- THE IT
MISTER CHOOSE. ORIGINAL BILL ON
THIS- BUT WE NEED TO GET US
THROUGH THE NEXT FIVE MONTHS TO
PREVENT A WAVE OF MASS
DEFECTIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WITH NO
CLEAR END IN SIGHT. AT THE SAME
TIME THE UNPRECEDENTED JOB
LOSSES FELT BY TENANTS HAVE
LEFT MANY LANDLORDS STRUGGLING
TO COVER THEIR COSTS THIS
BURDEN IS ESPECIALLY HARD FOR
SMALL MOM AND POP LANDLORDS WHO
DEPEND ON RENTAL INCOME TO
COVER THEIR LIVING EXPENSES. TO
HANDLE THIS EMERGENCY WE NEED
MEANINGFUL RENT RELIEF TO HELP
MAKE LANDLORDS HOLD WHILE
SHIELDING TENANTS FROM TAKING
ON MOUNTAINS OF DEBT FROM
THEY'RE MISSED PAYMENTS. THIS
YEAR TWO BILLS MOVE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX WHAT YOU HEARD EARLIER AND
SB FOURTEEN TEN. THE BILLS TOOK
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO SOLVE
THIS COST CRISIS. AFTER HOURS
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT REPRESENTS. A HYBRID OF
THESE TWO BILLS TO KEEP RENDERS
HOUSED AND LANDLORDS FROM
FORECLOSURES. FOR TENANTS AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT SET UP TWO
DIFFERENT PHASES. THE FIRST
PHASE FOCUSES ON THE INITIAL
PANDEMIC PERIOD MARCH
THIRTEENTH THROUGH SEPTEMBER
FIRST. AND PROVIDES IT A TENANT
CANNOT BE EVICTED FOR RENT
MISSED DURING THIS TIME. IT
ALSO SETS UP A SITUATION WHERE
PAST DUE RENT THAT IS STILL
OWED TO THE LANDLORD IS
CONVERTED TO A CONSUMER DEBT.
AND CAN BE COLLECTED IN SMALL
CLAIMS COURT TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR LANDLORDS TO RECOVER WHAT
THEY ARE OWED WITHOUT THE HIGH
COST OF LITIGATION. AND WITHOUT
CLOGGINGUP THE COURT SYSTEM.
THE NEXT PHASE IS THE
TRANSITION PERIOD FROM
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TO JANUARY THIRTY FOURTH FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO QUALIFY
FOR PROTECTIONS DURING THIS
PHASE TENANTS MUST ATTEST. THAT
THEY EXPERIENCED A COVERT
HARDSHIP BY SIGNING A
DECLARATION UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY IT'S A FORM THAT WILL
BE. UTILIZED BY BY EVERYONE.
AND HIGHINCOME TENANTS MAKING
AT LEAST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR OR AT LEAST A
HUNDRED AND 30% OF AM I MUST
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTED
PROOF OF HARDSHIP. IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS. THIS AT
PROTECTION DURING THIS PERIOD
OF TIME THE TENANT MUST ALSO.
PAY AT LEAST 25% OF THE RENT
OWED EACH MONTH DURING THIS
PERIOD AND THE REST OF THE
RENT- CANNOT BE THE BASIS FOR
AN EVICTION. IN OTHER WORDS
THEY'RE PROTECTED FROM
EVICTION. AND THAT IS ALSO
CONVERTED TO SYMBOL THAT. IF A
TENANT IS UNABLE TO PAY 25% OF
THE RENT DO THAT DUE TO THE- IN
THE NOTE THAT THE NORMAL
EVICTION PROCESSES MAY BEGIN
FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST SO IN ANY
CASE. TENANTS ARE PROTECTED
UNTIL FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO SET UP A SITUATION
WHERE THERE'S AN INCENTIVE TO
AT LEAST PAY 25% A YEAR RENT-
AND- AND IF SO THAT THESE.
LANDLORDS HAVE SOME CASH COMING
IN AND- DURING THAT TIME OF. A
DIFFICULT TIME SO EVICTIONS
UNRELATED TO NON PAYMENT OF
RENT. CAN BEGIN AGAIN ON
SEPTEMBER SECOND TWENTY TWENTY.
UNLESS THERE'S A LOCAL
ORDINANCE IN PLACE. THAT
PREVENTS IT. THIS ALSO PROTECTS
THE AUTHORITY OF LOCAL EXISTING
LOCAL ORDINANCES SO TENANTS IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE MORE
PROTECTIVE LOCAL ORDINANCES CAN
STILL RELY ON THOSE PROTECTIONS
UNTIL THEY EXPIRE IN WHICH CASE
THIS. ORDINANCE ARE THIS- BILL
CONTROLS THE THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LANDLORD AND THE TENANT AND ANY
EVICTIONS. FOR LANDLORDS THIS
BILL EXPANDS THE HOMEOWNERS
BILL OF RIGHTS ANTI FORECLOSURE
PROTECTIONS TO SMALL LANDLORDS
AND PUTS IN PLACE CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURES. TO REQUIRE
BANKS TO FOLLOW APPLICABLES
FEDERAL GUIDELINES REGARDING
BORROWER OPTIONS AFTER OFFERING
COVE IN NINETEEN RELATED
RELATED FORBEARANCE. AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT IT'S A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION AND AFTER THIS BILL IS
SIGNED OUR WORK CONTINUES TO
PREPARE FOR THE NEW YEAR AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT REQUIRES
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP. WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
DIRECT FUTURE FEDERAL STIMULUS
MONEY INTO RELIEF FOR TENANTS
LANDLORDS AND HOMEOWNERS THERE
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
DIFFERENT SMALL LITTLE MOVING
PARTS OF PROTECTIONS- I'M GOING
TO THOSE IF YOU REALLY WOULD
LIKE ME TO BUT SUFFICE IT TO
SAY THAT OUR GOAL HERE. WAS TO
PROTECT TENANTS SO THEY WOULD
NOT GET EVICTED. AND TO-
ENCOURAGED THE BANKS AND TO GET
THEM INVOLVED IN MAKING SURE
THAT THEY DON'T FOR CLOSE ON-
PROPERTIES THAT- AT OWN
PROPERTIES PERIOD BECAUSE ONCE
THEY START FORECLOSURE
PROCEEDINGS AND TENANTS LOSE
LOSE IT CIGNA. PART TO SO DO.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TODAYAND TO ASSIST WITH
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS BRIAN A
GUSTO ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. AND
DEBRA CARLTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
pCABALLERO. AT THIS POINT IN
TIME LET'S GO TO THE PHONES WE
ARE. GOING TO ALLOW OUR MAIN
WITNESSES A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE. I AM ALSO
ADVISED THAT WE HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES WHO ARE GOING TO
SPEAK. IN STRONG NEUTRALITY. AS
WELL WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM
THIRTY SECONDS EACH ON. A ONE
ON EITHER SIDE WELL IT'S HARD
TO KNOW NEUTRALS ARE I GUESS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN THE MIDDLE
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THERE
ARE TWO PEOPLE WHO HAVE-
SPECIFICALLY REQUESTED THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND WILL GIVE THEM
EACH THIRTY SECONDS BUT
MEANWHILE NOW WE WILL START-
WITH- OUR KEY WITNESSES WE HAVE
THOSE. TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
R. BRIAN A GUSTO. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- AND OUR
SECOND WITNESS IS DEBRA CARLTON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. MISTER MODERATORS
THAT CORRECT. MODERATORS WOULD
YOU CONFIRM THAT WE HAVE BRIAN
AUGUSTA AND DEBRA CARLTON ON
THE LINE AS OUR MAIN WITNESSES.
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE LINE AND
THEIR LINES ARE OPEN I THANK
YOU MADAM THE MODERATOR MY
APOLOGIES ALL RIGHT SO BRIAN
AUGUSTA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND- I LEFT OUT. THE
VERY IMPORTANT GROUP THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HE REPRESENTS BOTH AND
A MYSTERY PASSED IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO AHEADYOU HAVE. A
YOU AND MISS CARLTON HAVE A
TOTAL OF FOUR MINUTES PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BRIAN AUGUSTA. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
WHAT'S YOUR CENTER AND YOUR
MENTIONED ANYTHING USUAL TIMES
SORT OF UNUSUAL POSITIONS WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO SEE THIS.
BILL MOVE FORWARD BUT AS MY
COMMENTS WILL SUGGEST. WE DO
NOT SEE THIS BILL AS THE
SOLUTION AND WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO. JUDGE THIS COVER
NINETEEN CRISIS BEGAN WESTERN
CENTER AND GENERALLY FOUNDATION
ALONG WITH. MANY MANY OTHER
GROUPS HAVE BEEN SOUNDING THE
ALARM ABOUT THE WAVE OF MASS
EVICTION BUT- LIKELY TO. FROM
SUDDEN SHUTDOWN OF OUR ECONOMY
AND IMPACTING THE ABILITY OF
MILLIONS OF JAPANESE TO PAY THE
RENT THAT'S WHY WE'RE- RAVENOUS
DISCUSSION TODAY AND- WE'VE
ALSO WARNED ABOUT THE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES OF ALLOWING. ANY
OF ACTIONS TO PROCEED DURING A
PANDEMIC WHEN THE STATE OF URGE
PEOPLE TO STAY HOME IN ORDER TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND- STOP
THE SPREAD OF THIS DEADLY
DISEASE AND THAT. THE PRIMARY
THING THAT IS HELD BACK SINCE
WAVERED ACTIONS. BY THE PAUSE
ON FIXING CASES THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE BY. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
EMERGENCY RULE ONE. AND IT ALL
OF YOU KNOW THAT RULE WILL BE
REVEALED ON TUESDAY. TODAY'S
SATURDAY. L. BEFORE YOU
PROVIDES SOME PROTECTION FOR
TENANTS WHO DO HAVE BEEN AND
WILL CONTINUE. TO BE UNABLE TO
PAY THE RENT. IT NEEDS TO PASS.
BUT IT'S NOT NEARLY ENOUGH THIS
IS NOT. A COMPLETE SOLUTION TO
A LOOMING EVICTION CRISIS NOR
IS IT A LONG TERM SOLUTION WE
NEED TO THE VERY REAL FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC IS
HAVING A TENANTS. SMALL
LANDLORDS. IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROVIDERS. MANY TENANTS
WILL BE UNPROTECTED ONCE RULE
ONE IS REPEALED ON TUESDAY.
MOST AMERICANS OTHER THAN THOSE
FOR NONPAYMENT CAN MOVE FOR THE
VERY NEXT DAY. SO THOSE MOST
LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED BY THIS
OUR LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK AND
BROWN RENTERS THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALSO DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE CODE CRISIS.
THE LAW TO RULE ONE MUST BE
ADDRESSED IF WE ARE TO AVOID A
CATASTROPHE. OUR FIRM POSITION
THAT WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO.
CONTAIN THE COAT TO COVER
NINETEEN ALLOWING ANY OF
ACTIONS OTHER THAN THOSE
NECESSARY FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
DANGEROUS AND CONTRARY TO
PUBLIC HEALTH DIRECTOR SO WELL
WHAT YOU VOTE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD THE GROUP. THE PROPOSAL
IS REPORTED TODAY. WE WHICH WE
URGE YOU TO DO. WE WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT OUR COLLECTIVE WORK
IS NOT DONE ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU A LOT MORE THANK YOU MISTER
GASTON APPRECIATED. OUR NEXT
WITNESSES DEBRA CARLTON WHO HAS
A MINUTE AND FORTY SECONDS. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DEBRA
CARLTON THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION- WELL
APARTMENT IS OUR IN OUR NAME I
WANT TO SAY THAT- 75% OF OUR
MEMBERS. OWN LESS THAN TEN
UNITS IT'S BEEN A VERY BIG
STRUGGLE FOR US AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE PROVISIONS OF THE
SPELL. AND WHILE YOU'VE HEARD
OPPOSITION ON PREVIOUS COVER
NINETEEN BILLS IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
OUR POSITION BUT SOMETHING HAS
TO BE DONE TO PROVIDE HELP FOR
TENANTS. WHO ARE TRULY AFFECTED
BY COBIT NINETEEN AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE COMPENSATION FOR
LANDLORDS ESPECIALLY MOM AND
POP OWNERS AT RISK OF
FORECLOSURE. OR THOSE WHO ARE
RETIRED AND DEPEND ON THIS
INCOME BUT THEY HAVE NOT
RECEIVED BY WAY OF RENT PER
MONTH. SO THE BOTH TO HAVE A
CAME TOGETHER TO PROVIDE INPUT
ON AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND
MET. IT'S NOT THE PERFECT
SOLUTION EVERYONE INVOLVED
WOULD HAVE WANTED MUCH MORE FOR
THEIR MEMBERS AND THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. WE ALL KNOW THAT
TO TRULY ADDRESS THE CRISIS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO
STEP UP. COBIT IMPACT RENTERS
NEED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE SO
THAT THEY CAN PAY THEIR RENT.
IF RENT CONTINUES O GO UNPAID
HELPING PROVIDERS WILL EITHER
FACE FORECLOSURE OR IF THEY CAN
HANDLE SELLER CONVERT THEIR
PROPERTIES. THAT MAY MEAN
TENANTS WILL LOSE THEIR HOMES
IN THE END AND THE SMALLER
PROPERTIES HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
LOSING THESE UNITS WOULD WORSEN
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SHORTAGE.
AS A BUYING TO GET THAT THAT
OUR WORK IS NOT DONE AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT IS A TEMPORARY
SOLUTION AND WE COMMIT TO WORK
ON. FINDING BETTER SOLUTIONS
GOING FORWARD. OWNERS AND
TENANTS ALIKE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MISS CARLTON APPRECIATE
THAT. ALL RIGHT AT THIS TIME WE
WILL. GO TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. AND I
WANT TO REMIND THOSE QUEUING.
SUPPORT WE ARE ASKING YOU TO
ONLY STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE MEASURE THAT IS ALL WE ARE
GOING TO PERMIT AT THIS POINT
IN TIME AND WE HAVE HAD TO OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST HEARING
ON A MUCH MORE ROBUST VERSION
OF THIS BILL IT TOOK SIX HOURS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT NOW
NOR DO I THINK IT IS A
NECESSARY TO. PROTRACTED
PROCEEDINGS SO WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE WHAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
PLEASE IS YOUR NAME. YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
AND IF YOU HAVE MORE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SAY. A PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMITTED IF YOU
LIKE IN WRITING. TO THE
PRESSURE OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY WE'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR COMMENTS-
EXTENDED COMMENTS THERE. SO
WITH THAT- MODERATOR IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT. WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU I'M SORRY
I FORGOT TO LOG IN WE DO HAVE A
AN OVERFLOW ROOM WHICH I THINK
IS A MISNOMER AS YOU SEE THERE
IS. NO ONE THERE. IS THERE
ANYONE BY THE WAY BEFORE WE
START ON THE PHONE SYSTEM
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
IN THIS ROOM. NO ONE HERE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM I
BELIEVE THAT FROM ONE TWELVE.
TWENTY FORTY. NO. I ONE TWELVE
AND THERE'S NO ONE THERE SO
LET'S GO TO THE PHONES-
MODERATOR COULD YOU. PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND LINE UP FOR QUEUE UP
THE FOLKS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST MINE NUMBER. PLEASE GO
AHEAD TWELVE YOUR LINE. YOUR A.
B. SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS OF MISTER
GOTTEN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOUIS
LOUIS MARMANDE MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE MISTER GOT
THAT THANK YOU SIR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NIN EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROB
WILSON WITH A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS KEVIN
GOULD WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON NOT INSURED MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
LONDON BREED THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DANIEL CANDLE CARDS
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PAT ARAMBULA AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION ON AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MY
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LATER MEANING
THEY HAVE TO LOOK LIKE A PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FEEL THE
SOV SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI REPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER WITNESSES IN Q.
REGULATE SO MAKE SURE OF ANYONE
ELSE WISHES TO CALL IN TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF. AB.
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE DO
SO NOW. SCHMIDT A MODERATOR TO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER WITNESSES ON
THE LINE ALL RIGHT WE WILL. NOW
GO AHEAD AND PROCEED TO HEAR.
THE SAME PROCESS FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FOR MINUTES- TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR HOWEVER YOU
WISH TO. SPEND THAT TIME WE
HAVE. I BELIEVE RON KINGSTON
REPRESENTING VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS- ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IS THAT
CORRECT MADAM MODERATOR. YES WE
HAVE RUN KICKS AND CREAM JUST
THE. THE LINES ARE OPEN. ALL
RIGHT MISTER MISTER KING TO
JUST SECOND SO WE CAN CLARIFY-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS YOU ARE.
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION THERE
ARE TWO OTHER PEOPLE ON THE
LINE WHO ORGANISED WHO ARE
NEUTRAL AND WE'RE GONNA GIVE
THEM EACH THIRTY SECOND SO. YOU
SIR DON'T NEED TO TAKE THE FULL
FOUR MINUTES BUT THE OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN. GIVEN THE SAME. IT
OPPORTUNITY AS THE SUPPORT SO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR UP TO
FOUR MINUTES. ALL BALK QUE
QUESTION TO MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
WORKING STAND I REPRESENT- BY-
THE ASSOCIATIONS YOUR
PARTICIPATION ORANGE COUNTY
APARTMENT SO SHE AGING
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES THE
EAST BAY RAIL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND TOOL FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING ASSOCIATIONS. HAVE
NOTHING BUT DEEP RESTRICTED
PROPERTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- RIGHT YEAR CREE
A DEAL OF HARDSHIP. THANK IT IS
THE FACT MILLIONS THERE IS NOT
ONE. OR GROUP TO HALT. COBA DR
CHAIM HAS LARGELY RESULTED IN A
MOTIONAL AND FINANCIAL STRAIN
OF LANDLORD AND TENANT NOT JUST
ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER. WE HAVE
NOT BUT SHE- EIGHT HOURS AND AS
I WILL EXPLAIN SB TWENTY
CONSULTANT HAS OUTLINED THERE
ARE WE HI. THAT YOU NEED BILL
ADDRESSES AND HOW TO REPAY AND
REMAIN AT THE SESSION NINE
BILLION ONE. ADDRESS THE MARCH
ONE THROUGH AUGUST. THIRTY ONE
ALL YEAH EVEN IF IT HAS NOT
BEEN PAID OVER THE SIX MONTH
PERIOD. CAN BE REPAID AS LATE
AS MARCH. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THAT'S SIMPLY TOO WARM IT WILL
CREATE MASSIVE STRAIN- AS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED- BANKRUPTCY OR
FORECLOSURE NAY AND WILL RESULT
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN OUR
MINDS BECAUSE WE CAN'T WAIT FOR
REPAYMENT. THAT LEADS IN THE
CAR IT WILL CREATE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
LANDLORD DURING THIS. EIGHT
BILLION IN ALL THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY LONG WAIT PERIODS
THAT ARE ENJOYED NUMBER TWO IS
MARK. SORRY SEPTEMBER ONE
THROUGH THE END OF MARCH NEXT
YEAR CORRECT ONLY WILL HAVE TO
PAY 25% THAT IS NOT ANYWHERE
NEAR- I'M NOT INCOME. FOR THE
OWNERS TO PAY FOR WHAT AREAS IN
MAINTENANCE GENERAL. POROUS
EVEN HAD ONE ENCOURAGED TO DOES
NOT PERMIT US TO ASK FOR OR
RECEIVE ANY VERIFICATION THAT
THERE IS A HARDSHIP THE ONLY
THING WE HAVE TO DO SIGNED A
DECLARATION STATING THAT THEY
HAVE SOME FORM OF- COLD RELATED
HARDSHIP. IT COULD BE SMALL IT
COULD BE LARGE SMALL ARE CREATE
A BENEFIT WHICH WE DON'T
BELIEVE IS A CORPORATE. BECAUSE
WE DON'T KNOW THAT. OF HARDSHIP
AND THAT WILL CREATE TREMENDOUS
PRESSURE ON US TO DELIVER FOR.
YEAH YOU ALSO SAYS THAT THERE
THERE IS A HIGH INCOME.
EXEMPTION THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
WHO THE WAY IT'S WITH. HE
CARRIED IT OUT THAT IS A HIGH
INCOME WAGE EARNER OR BETTER OR
NOT 30% OF THE- ADJUSTED MEDIAN
INCOME. SIMPLY JUST HAVE TO
DECLARE THAT THEY TO HAVE A
HARDSHIP SO THERE IS A MASSIVE
HOLE IN THIS BILL. ULTIMATELY
ENCOURAGE THREE YEARS AFTER
FEBRUARY WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
WILL BE BACK TO FUNDS THAT
AREN'T QUITE YOU HAVE FIFTEEN
SECONDS FIFTEEN SECONDS SIR
OKAY. THANK YOU. FOR THE
REMINDER. SO IN ALL DUE RESPECT.
WE HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
PROBLEMS WITH THIS BECAUSE
WHILE WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
VERIFICATION LOCAL LOANS. IN
FORBEARANCE NOBODY ELSE THANK
YOU SIR AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY YOU'VE YOU'VE GONE
OVER YOUR FOUR MINUTES SO WE
APPRECIATED UNDERSTAND THIS IS
A COMPLICATED MEASURE- AND
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS.
WITH THAT- DO WE HAVE- ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. I IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NO ONE HERE. LET'S GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE LET'S TAKE
IT. OVER TO THE PHONES. AND
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
TO QUEUE UP THOSE WAITING TO
TESTIFY OR SHOULD I SAY
INDICATE THOSE WHO ARE WAITING
TO TESTIFY. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORPHANAGE THAT
WE ARE. READY TO TAKE THEIR
TESTIMONY AND I WANT TO REMIND
THOSE WHO ARE QUEUING UP IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. THE
ONLY STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. WITH THAT MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN A POSITION OF AB THIRTY
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN A POSITION OF AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN OUR FIRST MY NUMBER IS
NINE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS STEVE CARLSON
FOR THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES- IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MIND
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO SNACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE
HOME PARK OWNERS ALLIANCE
ACKNOWLEDGES WE'RE NOT NOT
POSITION- WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL AND TRAIN. BUT WANTED TO
QUICKLY YOU KNOW ANY ANY ANY
CONCERN FOR MOBILE HOME PARKS
IN THE BILL WHICH IS SIMPLY
THAT- WELL IT DOES ALLOW-
CERTAIN JUST CAUSE EVICTION
PROCEEDINGS. RECORD FOR
APARTMENT. NOT ALLOWED FOR
MOBILE HOME PARK SCHOOL ALSO
ALLOWED WOMEN. JEFF
CONTRAVENTIONS. UNDER CIVIL
CODE. WELL I CAN DEFINITELY LAW
PLANO THAN AT ANY RATE I'M SURE
YOU KNOW WHAT. THEY ARE AT HAND
OF MY ISSUES THIS THE THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE GO YOUR- ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATED PAPA'S NOW ON
PLEASE. OPPA ONLY SURE ANYONE
ELSE WHO TO SPEAK AFFILIATE AND
POSITION IN OP TO THIS BILL.
OUR LAST CALLER IN Q. IS
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S GO AHEAD
AND LET HIM INDICATE HIS NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE. ONE
FIFTY. ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM SORRY MY APOLOGIES
MY NAME IS BARBARA SHELL AND
I'M WITH HOW SACRAMENTO THE
LOCAL YIMBY GROUP HERE AND I
AM- CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ZERO EIGHT APOLOGIES
BECAUSE I GOT DISCONNECTED AND
QUITE ALRIGHT. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WITH ME IT
IS NOTED AND NOW WE WILL- IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER. WITNESSES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT LET'S TAKE ANOTHER TEN OR
FIFTEEN SECONDS ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TO AB THIRTY EIGHTY. EIGHT THIS
IS YOUR MOMENT TO SIGN UP IN
THE QUEUE. AND GIVE US YOUR
TESTIMONY. META MODERATORS SURE
ANYONE ON THE LINE. NO FURTHER
WITNESSES ALL RIGHT SO AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE WE
CAN LEAD TO WITNESSES WHO ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL- THEY ARE
KEY TO BAIL AND CATCH KAREEM
GREASY WHO- WE'RE GONNA GIVE
THEM EACH THIRTY SECONDS. TO
GIVE US THEIR PERSPECTIVE AND-
WILL START NOW WITH A MS BILLS
THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR THIRTY
SECONDS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AGAIN KATE BALBOA
CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS MOSTLY
MARC SMALL AND MEDIUM PROPERTY
OWNERS IN THE STATE THE POST TO
THE CORPORATE OWNERS ONLY HAVE
HALF OVER HALF A MILLION UNITS
STATEWIDE. WHAT WE DO NOT HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION WE WOULD BE
REMISS IF WE DID NOT EXPRESS
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT MY NOT
LETTER SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY MAINLY ONLY
REQUIRING TENANTS TO PAY TWENTY
FIVE. PERCENT OF THE RENT DUE
FROM SEPTEMBER ON BY THE END OF
THIS COMING JANUARY IS REALLY
TOUGH FOR MEMBERS AND BURDEN
PROPERTY OWNERS WITH THE COST
HOW WITHOUT MUCH RELIEF WHILE
WE RECOGNIZE THE MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE. WE WOULD POINT OUT
THAT IT IS LIMITED HAVING SAID
THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT AND NEGOTIATION WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
LEGISLATURE INCLUSION OF
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS
MEANS TESTING PREEMPTION AND
THE DIRECTIVE TO WORK AROUND
THE SYSTEM. THANK REWARDED FOR
THE COLLABORATION NEXT YEAR
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN COMMON
APPRECIATE. IT NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. KARIMABAD SHE. GOOD
MORNING SURE JACKSON MEMBERS OR
GOOD AFTERNOON RATHER- CREAM
GREASY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WANNSEE
OURS NEUTRAL MAYBE THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WE WISH TO EXPRESS
CONCERN THAT THE LEGISLATION
DOES NOT SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESS
THE SEVERE IMPACTS OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC ON SMALL MOM
AND POP HOUSING PROVIDERS THIS
YEAR LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THE INTERIM
ON PROPOSAL THAT INCLUDED
DRESSING PUT THE PLIGHT. FACING
SMALL HOUSING PROVIDER DUE TO
THE COLD NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DIETS I JUST WANNA MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS WE HAD A HEARING LAST
WEEK. ON THIS IT TOOK ABOUT SIX
HOURS. AND CLEAR THE BILL THAT
WAS PRESENTED TO US THEN. IT
WAS A MORE COMPREHENSIVE AND
SUBSTANTIAL IN BROADER BILL.
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
THE PENSION TRUST AFFECT
TENANTS DOESN'T TRUST AFFECT
LANDLORDS. IT DOESN'T JUST
AFFECT HOMEOWNERS IT AFFECTS
THEM ALL TOGETHER. AND WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY IS CLEARLY
A VERY WATERED DOWN VERSION OF
THAT EFFORT I LOOK AT THIS IS A
THREE LEGGED STOOL YOU CAN'T
ADDRESS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE OTHER
TWO FACETS OF IT. AND THOSE
OTHER TWO FACETS ARE NUMBER ONE
THE TENANTS RIGHT NOW ARE
HURTING BECAUSE OF COLD IT. AND
HAD WE HAD LEGITIMATE AND
ROBUST LEADERSHIP ON A NATIONAL
BASIS I DO NOT BELIEVE WE WOULD
BE WHERE WE ARE TODAY. BUT THAT
BEING SAID WE ARE HERE AND WE
ARE HAVING TO PICK UP THE
PIECES OF A DISASTROUS FEDERAL
POLICY ON THIS ISSUE LET'S MAKE
LET'S LET LET'S LET'S BE HONEST
ABOUT IT. SO HERE WE ARE PEOPLE
ARRIVE TO WORK PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING. THE A JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. EXTENDED A MORATORIUM
BUT THAT HAS NOW ENDED IT IS ON
US IT IS OUR JOB NOW TO STEP
FORWARD AND PASS LEGISLATION.
AND IDEA- FELT SO STRONGLY
ABOUT WHAT WE WERE DOING LAST
WEEK THAT I ACTUALLY- IT BECAME
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR THE BILL
WORKED VERY HARD WITH THE- THE
AUTHORS- IN HOPES THAT WE COULD
ADDRESS. THE REALITIES OF THIS
IS A THREE LEGGED STOOL. AND
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS OUR OUR MORTGAGE
HOLDERS ARE BANKS THEY DO NOT
WANT TO PARTICIPATE. AND
BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL ISSUES
FEDERAL PREEMPTION THIS BILL
DOESN'T REALLY ADDRESS THAT
THIRD LEG OF THE STOOL IN ANY
MEANINGFUL WAY. SO HERE WE ARE
TRYING TO BALANCE A THREE
LEGGED STOOL ON TO LEX. WE HAVE
TENANTS WHO ARE ABOUT TO GET
EVICTED. YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T
HAVE SECURITY IN YOUR HOME YOU
WERE VERY LITTLE. PEOPLE NEED
TO BE SECURE IN WHERE THEY LIVE
FOR THEMSELVES AND FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. AND LANDLORDS
PARTICULARLY SMALL ONES WHO ARE
FREQUENTLY OPERATE ON THE BASIS
OF THE MONEY THAT COMES INTO
THEM TO PAY RENT SO THEY CAN
PAY THE MORTGAGE AND THE
UTILITIES AND OTHER EXPENSES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT ALSO NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PAY THE MORTGAGE.
SO THEY NEED SOME FORBEARANCE.
BY THE BANKS. AND THE BANKS ARE
WILLING TO PLAY BALL IN IT THEY
ARE IN A VERY LIMITED WAY. AND
YOU KNOW WHAT. WE'RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER. BY A WAY FOR
CALLING UPON THE LANDLORDS TO
FORBEAR. AND TO GET GVE THESE
TENETS OF BREAKING ASKED
TENANTS TO PAY. AT LEAST 25%
THAT SEEMS LIKE A FAIR THING TO
DO AND DO ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE TO PROTECT THE SMALL
LANDLORDS IN TERMS OF THE
TENANT AND TO PROTECT THE
TENANTS. THAT THE BANKS AND THE
MORTGAGE HOLDERS ARE TO NOTHING.
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
DISAPPOINTED I AM THAT THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN WILLING TO STEP
UP- WORKERS HAVE SACRIFICED
BECAUSE OF THIS- SO MANY NEW.
LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE
LITERALLY PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE. TO PROVIDE THOSE
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS OF OUR
SOCIETY. DURING THIS TIME AND
HAVE SUFFERED COMMENSURATELY
WITH FAT AND MANY OF THEM ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE A
SAVINGS ACCOUNT SO THAT THEY
CAN RIDE THROUGH THIS AND PAY
THE RENT. BUT THEY ARE EQUALLY
IS ENTITLED TO HAVE A PLACE TO
LIVE AS ANYONE ELSE. NOW YOU
KNOW WE ARE ASKING LANDLORDS TO
MAKE SOME SACRIFICES AND WE'VE
HEARD I'M SURE FOR MANY OF THEM
WHO HAVEN'T BEEN PAID RENTED
MANY MONTHS. AND ARE STRUGGLING
THEMSELVES AND THAT IS TRUE.
OUR AND TOUGH THEY ARE
SHOULDERING THEIR SHARE OF THE
BURDEN AND WE ARE ASKING THEM
TO DO MORE. WITH THIS BILL. I
BOUGHT. SOME LANDLORDS HAVE
FALLEN BEHIND AND OR WILL FALL
BEHIND WHAT THEY OWE TO THE
BANKS AND SO THAT'S WHY AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX- CALLED
UPON THE BANKS TO DO THEIR FAIR
SHARE AS WELL. BANKS LIKE JP
MORGAN CITI BANK BANK OF
AMERICA WELLS FARGO JUST TO
NAME A FEW THE VERY BANKS THAT
WE COLLECTIVELY AS TAXPAYERS
BAILED OUT OF THEIR MASS JUST A
DECADE AGO. HAVE NOT STEPPED UP.
NOW AT. TRYING NOT TO GET TOO
ANGRY ABOUT THIS. BUT THE FACT
IS WE HAVE PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE THEY'RE DESPERATE TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES WHERE
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE
THIS IS UNFAIR TO THEM AS WELL.
AND YET THIS IS THE BEST WE CAN
DO IN THIS SITUATION AND I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT THAT'S
BEEN UNDERTAKEN APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT- THE AUTHORS SHOULD
HAVE DONE AND THEIR STAFFS IN
THIS. AND APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT. WE HAVE LIMITATIONS
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE LAWS ARE
WRITTEN- THIS BILL PASSED SO
VERY LITTLE OF THE BANKS AND
THEREFORE PROVIDES SUCH COLD
COMFORT. TO THE SMALL LANDLORDS
AND HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE DOING
THEIR PART AND LET'S BE HONEST
EXTENSION OF THE HOMEOWNERS
BILL OF RIGHTS CONTAINED IN
THIS BILL WAS ALREADY MOVING
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATURE ON
CONSENT. AND THEN THE SO CALLED
FORBEARANCE PIECE OF THIS BILL
WAS WRITTEN BY THE BANKS. FOR
BY THEM AND FOR THEM. IT OFFERS
NOTHING OF SUBSTANCE TO
BORROWERS. THERE IS NO THIRD
LEG ON THE STOOL IT ALLOWS
BANKS TO DENY DISTRESSED
BORROWERS FORBEARANCE FOR ANY
REASON WHATSOEVER WITH NEARLY
ABSOLUTE IMPUNITY. EVEN THE
CREDIT UNIONS AND SMALL
COMMUNITY LENDERS WHO
JUSTIFIABLY SOUGHT AN EXEMPTION
FROM THE MORE ONEROUS
REQUIREMENTS OF AB AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX ARGUABLY. ARE
PERFECTLY CONTENT TO BE A PART
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE IT ASKED
NEXT TO NOTHING OF THEM AS WELL.
SEVERAL OF OUR SISTER STATES
HOWEVER OREGON NEW YORK
MASSACHUSETTS HAVE PASSED SOME
KIND OF MORATORIUM ON
FORECLOSURE. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE AT LEAST OR AT LEAST
REFUSE TO GIVE BANKS READY
ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS OF OUR
NON JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE
PROCESS IF THEY REFUSE TO OFFER
OUR BORROWERS FORBEARANCE. SO
LET ME LET ME ADD FOR CLARITY I
DO NOT BLAME. ANYONE ANY OF OUR
AUTHORS HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOUGHT HARD FORD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON OF COURSE HAD
FOUGHT HARD TO REQUIRE THE
BANKS TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY. WHAT ARE THE
BANKS. THE BANKS HAVE A LOT OF
POWER THE BANKS SEEM TO BE
HISTORICALLY ABLE TO GET AWAY
WITH DOING JUST ABOUT ANYTHING
TO THE DETRIMENT OF THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE. AND ARGUABLY OF
THIS NATION AND YET WE JUST WE
JUST TAXPAYERS CONSISTENTLY A
BAIL THEM OUT. SO WE'RE KIND OF
LEFT IT WITH A HOBSON'S CHOICE
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BECAUSE OTHERWISE IN A
FEW DAYS PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
OUT ON THE STREET. NOT BECAUSE
I KNOW JUST JUST REALLY WANT TO
DO THAT. BUT MANY OF THEM HAVE
NO CHOICE EITHER. AND SO THE
BURDEN OR THE RESPONSIBILITY I
SHOULD SAY. TO MAKE THIS WORK
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA LARGE
WITH THE BANKS WERE WILLING TO
DO NOTHING. AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT BACK NEXT THAT
NEXT YEAR IN JANUARY WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME CLEARLY
HERE. I WON'T BE HERE BUT I
KNOW MANY OF YOU WILL AND I
HOPE THAT YOU TAKE UP THIS THIS
MANTLE THAT YOU FIGHT HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE. DOES
THEIR FAIR SHARE SURE HERE AND
JOB THAT WE AT THAT POINT IN
TIME- WILL HAVE TO CONFRONT
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE AS YOU SAY
THIS GOES ONLY THROUGH THE END
OF JANUARY AND THEN THEY'LL BE
MORE PAIN. AND MORE
HOMELESSNESS AND MORE ANGST AND
MORE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. FOR
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE FOR
THEIR CHILDREN AS A GROUP AND
SAY TRY TO FIND A WAY TO PAY
THE RENT THE BACKGROUND THAT
THEY ALSO. HAD TO PAY THE OTHER
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH LIVING
THROUGH THIS DISASTROUS
PANDEMIC THE DIDN'T HAVE TO BE.
SO I HOPE THAT TO THE NEXT YEAR
YOU WILL REMEMBER THIS BILL
REMEMBER WHO STEPPED UP TO DO
THEIR PART. AND WHO DID NOT AND
THEN FOR HEAVEN'S SAKES LET US
NOT LET THE BANKS GET AWAY WITH
THIS AGAIN. AND WITHOUT BOB I
NOTED TO SENATOR BORCHERS YOU
HAVE YOUR HAND UP PHOTO BY
SENATOR MONNING. AND SENATOR US
SENATOR BOARD JUST GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR THANK YOU MANAGER.
THIS IS CERTAINLY A DIFFERENT
FORMAT- THERE WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH DURING THAT SIX HOUR
ORDEAL LAST WEEK- THERE I THINK
THEY HAVE BEEN SOME.
RECOGNIZABLE IMPROVEMENTS. AS I
WENT THROUGH THIS ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT I'VE HAD IS I
JUST GOT THIS PROBABLY JUST
LIKE THE REST OF YOU I JUST GOT
THE BILL I JUST GOT THE ROUGH
OVERVIEW AND SOME OF THE
ANALYSIS SO LITERALLY. I DON'T
HAVE A LOT TO GO ON. AND THAT
MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE AS A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE PEOPLE RELY ON US BEING
FULLY BRIEFED AND AWARE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT PROVISIONS IN A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. SO BUT
LET ME MENTION A COUPLE THINGS
I THINK ARE IMPROVEMENTS ONE I
THINK THE PENALTY OF PERJURY
THAT WAS SOMETHING I ADVOCATED
FOR. LAST WEEK- WITH THE
INITIAL DRAFT IT HAD DID NOT.
PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF
PROTECTION- THE SHORTENED
TIMELINE I THINK IS BETTER
JANUARY TWENTY ONE AS OPPOSED
TO WHAT WAS BEFORE THE TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. OF RENTS- I THINK
IS CERTAINLY HELPFUL. STANDS UP
MAKING CERTAIN THAT THE
EXISTING LANDLORD TENANT
RIGHTS- THAT WOULD NORMALLY
ALLOW A LANDLORD TO REVIEW. HOW
WELL AS A- A RENTER'S
PERFORMING IN THE COMPLEX IN
OTHER BREAKING IN THE OTHER
UNRELATED TO COPE AND FINANCIAL
ISSUES RULES STILL GIVES THEM
AND ALLOWS THEM THE POWER TO-
MOVE ON INTERDICTION AS
APPROPRIATE. ALBOM'S THAT I SEE
RIGHT NOW IT IS. ONE I THINK
CALIFORNIA'S STILL IT CANNOT
DICTATE TO THE BANKS. WHAT THEY
EXPECT THE BANKS TO PERFORM AND
I THINK THE CHAIRWOMAN WENT
INTO SOME DETAIL ON- HOW THE
BANKS ARE NOT UNDER ANY TYPE OF
OBLIGATION CURRENTLY AND I'M
REPRESENTS ELEVEN COUNTIES ALL
OR PARTS OF ELEVEN COUNTIES AND
WIENER REPRESENT A LOT OF
FOLKS. WHO HAVE SMALL FOR AN
UNDER UNIT COMPLEXES THEY'RE
GETTING HIT JUST LIKE THE
RANGERS ARE GETTING IT THEY'RE
GETTING AT SO THIS REALLY IS A
BALANCING ACT. AND I THINK ONE
THING THAT IS TERRIBLY
DISCONCERTING IS WE HAVE NOT
DEVISED. THROUGH NEGOTIATION OF
WAR THROUGH LEGISLATION AWAY
THAT CALIFORNIA STEPS UP. AND
OFFERS SOME SUPPORT TO THE
BORROWER THE OWNER OF THE
COMPLEX- FOR EXAMPLE WHY ISN'T
THERE A STATE TAX CREDIT THAT
WAS PART OF THIS THAT WOULD
SOFTEN THE BLOW TO FOLKS THAT
ARE WITHOUT. RECEIVING RENTS
WHY IS THERE NOT A STATE FUNDS
ARE CREATED THAT COULD BE OF
ASSISTANCE NOT UNLIKE THE ONES
THAT WE HAVE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. SO. BY ALLOWING THIS TO
MOVE FORWARD. WE'RE GOING TO BE
HELPING BUT ALSO HURTING THE
INDUSTRY I THINK LONG TERM ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK IS
OF IT SHOULD BE OF CONCERN IS
WHAT IS THIS GOING TO DO TO
LIQUIDITY AND ACCESS TO CAPITAL
MOVING FORWARD. BECAUSE THE
BORROWERS. IT WAS A RISK THEN
LENDERS ARE GOING TO PROBABLY
STEP IN THE CRITERIA THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM ACCESS TO CAPITAL SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INCREASING-
THE VOLUME OF HOMES THAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
SATISFYING A SHORT TERM PROBLEM
BUT POTENTIALLY CREATING AN
INTERMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
LIQUIDITY AND ACCESS TO CAPITAL
PROBLEM. I DON'T THINK I'M
STATING THINGS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE. NOT WRESTLED WITH BECAUSE
THIS IS AN IMPERFECT SITUATION
AND IT'S- UNDER THE GUN- WE
ONLY HAVE A DAY AND A HALF OR
OR ROUGHLY TWO DAYS LEFT IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WERE IN PLACE ARE SET TO
EXPIRE SO WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING. THAT BAD THINGS WILL
ALMOST CERTAINLY HAPPEN. BUT
MANAGER I'D LIKE TO IF I MAY
OPPOSE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
AND I DON'T KNOW TO WHOM THEY
SHOULD BE. ARE DIRECTED. MAYBE
TO- THE FLOOR MANAGER OF FOR
THIS BILL. MR CENTER BORCHERS
SHE'S ALSO A I THINK ONE OF THE
AUTHORS OF THE BILL SO I'M SURE
SHE'S MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
AND SHE IS INDEED THE PERSON TO
THE DIRECTOR QUESTIONS TO. ALL
RIGHT. SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS.
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE STRONG AND
PRIVATE CONTRACT RIGHTS. YOUR
OF OUR AMERICAN- SYSTEM. CAN
YOU IMAGINE A SCENARIO WHERE A
PARTY LET'S SEE A RENTER AND A
LANDLORD LET'S ASSUME THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST NOW GOING
INTO. A RENTAL AGREEMENT THAT
THEY CAN CONTRACT AROUND THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ALMOST AS
IF YOU'RE STE YOU'RE WAVING
LEGAL RIGHTS AS YOU WOULD IN
ANY OTHER TYPE OF CONTRACTUAL
ON NEGOTIATION IS THAT POSSIBLE
SENATOR A COUPLE HERE- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND AS A LAWYER
I'M SURE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWERS TO THAT QUESTION HAPPY
TO DO IT- LET ME JUST SAY THAT-
WE DO LIVE IN A IN A IN A
SOCIETY THAT BELIEVES. VERY
STRONGLY IN. IN CONTRACTS AND
UPLOADING THOSE CONTRACTS BUT
BY THE SAME TOKEN- THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE CHANGES TO STATE LAW
THAT- THAT ARE IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN IN THIS INSTANCE
WHAT WE CONTROL IS HOW YOU CAN
GET SOMEBODY OR HOW YOU CAN USE
THE AUTHORITY OF THE STATE.
WHICH IS THE SHERIFF TO BE ABLE
TO- EVICT SOMEBODY IT TO THE
COURTS AND THE SHERIFF AND SO
IN THIS INSTANCE IT WOULD BE
AGAINST PUBLIC POLICY TO ALLOW
LANDLORDS. TO CREATE A CONTRACT
THAT SAYS WE'RE GOING TO GO
WE'RE GOING TO GO OUTSIDE OF
THE LAW AND I GET TO A BIG DO
IF I WANT TO- UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SO. IT WOULD IT'S
MY OPINION THAT YOU CANNOT.
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT THAT
CONTRAVENES A LAW IS TO ME THAT
THIS PASSES AND IS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR- THAT IS SET UP TO
BE IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST TO
PROTECT LANDLORDS AND TENANT IT
TELLS THEM WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES ARE. AND I
ALSO THINK IF I MAY JUST ADD TO
THAT THE FACT IS THAT WE'RE
NUMBER AN EMERGENCY SITUATION
AND THAT DOES GIVE US A MUCH
BROADER POWERS AS WELL. FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WELL BEING
AND CERTAINLY IF THERE IS A- A
TO TERMINATE OR I BELIEVE. THAT
THE RIGHT OF CONTRACT HAS BEEN
UNDULY IT IMPROPERLY INTERFERED
WITH. WE HAVE A COURT SYSTEM
THAT WILL RESOLVE THAT ISSUE-
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS CENTER
BORCHERS. YES DOES- I WAS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
RELATES TO TWO MORE RESTRICTIVE
OR MORE ONEROUS LOCAL
ORDINANCES. SO DID I HEAR YOU
SAY THAT THIS BECOMES THE
DOMINANT BODY OF LAW. THAT
OVERRIDES MORE RESTRICTIVE
LOCAL ORDINANCES. I THINK I'D
HAVE TO ASK WHAT YOU MEAN BY
RESTRICTIVE ORDINANCES I'D
MENTIONED. IF YOU HAVE A LOCAL
I'D SAY MUNICIPALITY OR COUNTY
WITH WHICHEVER ENTITY HAD THE
LAND USE AUTHORITY- CREATED
CREATED A ROLE THAT THAT SAYS.
THAT SAYS THAT. YOU CAN.
DISALLOW. THE NORMAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO EVICT A PARTY
FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW IF
SOMEONE'S MAKES A LOT OF NOISE
OR HAS TOO MANY PEOPLE AT THE
PLACE WHERE THEY PARK THEIR
VEHICLES INAPPROPRIATELY IN THE
NORMAL- ARE OTHER EXAMPLES THAT
ALLOW INDIVIDUALS TO BE EVICTED
THAT THIS LEGISLATION STILL
ACKNOWLEDGES AS- ADEQUATE AND
ARE FORESEEABLE GROUNDS TO
MAINTAIN THE EVICTION POWERS.
WHAT IF THE LOWER- LOWER
MUNICIPALITY HAS RESTRICTIONS
AGAINST THAT SO DURING CONFLICT
WHICH ONE WOULD CONTROL SO I
KNOW THAT THERE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ENTITIES THAT HAVE
PASSED ORDINANCES TO PROTECT
TENANTS. AND THOSE PROTECTIONS
WOULD STAY IN PLACE I TELL AND
THEY'RE SET TO EXPIRE ON ON A
NATURAL DATE MOST OF THEM HAVE
A DATE. IN WHICH CASE STATE LAW
THIS LAW WOULD CONTROL WHEN WE
SET IT UP THAT WAY BECAUSE WE
WANT TENANTS TO KNOW THEY'VE
ARE THEY ALREADY KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTION WE WANT THEM TO
CONTINUE TO BE PROTECTED. AND
THEN ONCE THEY EXPIRE THIS
PARTICULAR LAW KICKS IN. SO IN
OTHER WORDS THIS IS. THE OTHER
LAW OR THIS LAW RATHER IT IS
SORT OF LIKE THE FLOOR THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY YEAH. OKAY LAST
QUESTION. FOR YOU DONE. ALL IN
HERE. I'M STILL POURING OVER
THIS BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME REALLY GOOD
WORK. ON THIS ISSUE I WANT TO
SPEND MORE TIME MAKING CERTAIN
THAT I CAN FOLLOW UP WITH FOLKS
WHO HAVE INSIGHTS INTO THE
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THOSE THAT
WILL BE IMPACTED. I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY- BUT I
WANTED FOLKS JUST. TO IT'S
WONDERFUL TO KNOW THAT I'M
GONNA BE DOING AS MUCH DUE
DILIGENCE AS POSSIBLE OVER THE
NEXT DAY OR SO WHENEVER THIS
COMES TO. A LOT OF THE FLOOR
THE FIGURE OUT IF THIS IS AS
WELL THOUGHT OUT AND AS AS WE
NEED FOR OUR FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WHAT I DON'T WANT TO
SEE HAPPEN IS THAT THIS GOES TO
JANUARY TWENTY ONE. IT COMES
BACK IT IS AS AN EMERGENCY ITEM
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT SAYS WE
NEED SIX MORE MONTHS OF THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH- FINANCIAL- STABILITY IN
THE MARKET. IN THAT WOULD FOR
ME I WOULD WOULD BE ON IT
UNACCEPTABLE IN THE SOME ON
THIS SIDE. BUT I THINK IT HAS
MERITS IN IT BUT IT DOES ITS
BEST TO BALANCE OUT THE NEEDS
BETWEEN THE LANDLORD THE TENANT
FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDER SO I
JUST WANT TO COMMENT THE NOTION
OF CALIFORNIA CREATING A FUND.
WHEN WE ARE SUFFERING A BUDGET
SHORTFALL AS A RESULT. OF THIS
COVERT PANDEMIC. AND THE FACT
THAT BECAUSE INACTION TOOK
PLACE WHERE THERE WAS INACTION
ON THE- FEDERAL LEVEL.
RESULTING IN OUR HAVING TO
LITERALLY SHUT THE STATE DOWN
FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AND STILL
CRAWLING BACK ON OUR KNEES TO
TRY TO GET REOPENED. BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF ANY CLEAR CUT
POLICIES- IT IS. HEART WERE
HARD PRESSED TO BE ABLE TO
START SETTING UP THESE FUNDS.
BANKS ARE MUCH BETTER EQUIPPED
TO DO IT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO IS THE MOST. EFFECTIVE AT
DOING THAT BECAUSE THEY CAN
PRINT MONEY. AND WE CAN'T OUR
REQUIREMENT IS A BALANCED
BUDGET- IN LET'S HOPE THAT
PERHAPS. WE CAN GET THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE THAT
FUNDING THAT TO YOU BELIEVE IS
APPROPRIATE- PERHAPS IT IS
APPROPRIATE. AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE THAT THE
BANKS ALSO TAKE PART IN THIS.
WHOLE PROCESS AS WELL BUT WITH
THAT. US SENATOR MONNING
FORESHORES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WANT TO JOIN IN
THANKING THE AUTHORS SENATOR
CAFIERO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO IN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW
IT'S ALSO BEEN INVOLVED IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS IN YOUR
COMMITTEE. MADAM CHAIR. THIS IS
AN IMPERFECT SOLUTION TO AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS IT'S A
STOP GAP MEASURE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IN TWO DAYS. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE GONNA FACE ARE
GONNA LOSE THE PROTECTION
EXTENDED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IT'S DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE. SOME PREDICTABILITY IN
PROTECTION MOVING FORWARD- BUT
THE OTHER CHALLENGE HERE IS WE
DON'T HAVE A PREDICTABLE. END
TO THE COVERT NINETEN CRISIS A
LOT OF THESE FOLKS WHO NEED
RELIEF. BE THEY A TENANT BE
THEIR PROPERTY OWNER WHO
STRUGGLING TO MAKE PAYMENTS
HAVE LOST JOBS. HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES. AND MAY CONTINUE TO BE
WITHOUT WORK THERE'S NOTHING.
MAGIC THAT HAPPENED SEPTEMBER
FIRST JUST THIRTY FIRST OR
FEBRUARY OF NEXT YEAR THE
GUARANTEES OUR ECONOMY IS
RESTORED IN COVERT NINETEEN IS
BEHIND US DESPITE PROCLAMATIONS
FROM CERTAIN ACTORS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THE COVERT
NINETEEN IS BEHIND THIS. WE'RE
APPROACHING TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DEATHS NATIONALLY THE
PROJECTION IS THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY HIT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DEATHS AND THERE ARE
SOME WHO SEEK TO IGNORE THAT
REALITY. BUT THAT REALITIES
BEING FELT THANK EVERYONE IN
THIS STATE SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OFTHIS TODAY BUT I
STILL I'VE HEARD FROM JUDGES IN
MY DISTRICT WHO WANT TO KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE THEY
FEAR THEY'RE GOING TO BE
FLOODED WITH THE VACATION-
LITIGATION. STARTING SEPTEMBER
FIRST THEY WANNA KNOW QUITE
QUITE SHOULD WE BE PLANNING FOR
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WHAT'S
THE LEGISLATURE DOING. I WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO HAVE SEEN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL- IN LIGHT OF
THE ONGOING PANDEMIC. EXTENDED
THE EMERGENCY RELIEF THAT HAD
BEEN EXTENDED EXPIRES SEPTEMBER
FIRST. I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
REASONS FOR THEIR RELUCTANCE
BUT APPARENTLY THEY FEAR.
LAWSUIT SWUNG MAYBE THEY SHOULD
BE STANDING UP FOR US AS WE
KNOW AS THE LEGISLATURE TRYING
TO STAND UP FOR THE PEOPLE.
THAT WE REPRESENT. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO SATISFY MULTIPLE
INTERESTS AND YET I THINK IT'S
UNREALISTIC TO THINK OF FAMILY
WITHOUT EMPLOYMENT. WITHOUT ANY
EXTENSION OF THE CARE SACKED OR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS- OR ANY
OTHER TYPE OF ECONOMIC RELIEF.
WILL BE ABLE TO PAY 25% SOME
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BE.
SACRIFICING FOOD OR MEDICINE TO
SCRAPE TOGETHER 25% OF THE RENT
THERE'S NO MAGIC NUMBER HERE
AND IF THE FAMILY. IS IMPACTED
BY COVERT NINETEEN. IN THIS IS.
TENANTS AND PROPERTY OWNERS- WE
LOOK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-IS THE CHAIR HAS SAID IN THE
INACTION OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO COMMIT TO
FURTHER ECONOMIC RELIEF NOT
JUST FOR CALIFORNIANS BUT FOR
ALL AMERICANS. IS AT THE CORE
OF THIS CRISIS. IN THE SOLUTION
IS NOT TO BE FOUND IN A LABORAT
PUZZLES OF YOU PAY 25% NOW AND
YOU CARRY THIS AND THAT AND
THEN IT TO DO AND THEN YOU CAN
BE TAKEN TO SMALL CLAIMS COURT
AND STILL FACE EVICTION. THAT'S
NOT A SOLUTION IT'S SOME FIRST
AID TO TRY TO FORESTALL. THE
INEVITABLE SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BUT WITH
THE RESERVATIONS THAT I HAVE
ARTICULATED AND THAT WE
SHOULDN'T WAIT UNTIL. JANUARY
OR FEBRUARY OF NEXT YEAR TO
START FIGURING OUT THE
SEQUENTIAL BILL I JUST SAY TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO.
THERE'S NO MAGIC DATE BY WHICH
THEY SHOULD END THE MAGIC DATE
REALLY BEHIND THIS AND OUR
ECONOMY IS RESTORED IN PEOPLE
CAN GO BACK TO WORK AND THEY
CAN WORK AND PAY THEIR RENT-
AND HAVE THE SECURITY OF THAT
INTEL WE'RE AT THAT POINT. THE
IN SECURITY WILL CONTINUE TO
HANG OVER THE HEADS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AMERICANS
AND THERE WILL BE MORE
HOMELESSNESS IT'LL BE MORE
SUFFERING FROM NOT JUST THE
DIRECT MEDICAL IMPACTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN BUT THE RELATED
IMPACTS OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES- SUBSTANCE ABUSE
EVERYTHING THAT'S UNFOLDING AS
A RESULT. OF OUR INABILITY. TO
GET IN FRONT OF COVERT NINETEEN
SO AGAIN I THINK THE AUTHORS
MORE OF A STATEMENT NOT REALLY
A QUESTION- I GUESS JUST IT TO
MAYBE. SHARE A QUESTION FROM.
WHAT'S THE COMMITMENT OF THE
PARTIES INVOLVED IN THIS
AGREEMENT TO KEEP WORKING
BETWEEN NO AND THE EXPIRATION
OF THESE TEMPORARY RELIEF
MEASURES. IT MADE UP EVERYONE
IS TO CONTINUE WORKING OVER THE
FALL TO START THE DAY AFTER
WE'RE DONE. WE KNOW THERE'S A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO AND PART OF
IT IS MAKE IS CONTINUING TO
COME TO THE TABLE I MEAN
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY HAS SAID
IT'S REALLY TRUE WE DON'T KNOW
WHEN THIS IS GOING TO END WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT THE STATE.
FISCAL SITUATIONS GOING TO BE-
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO START GOING BACK
TO WORK THE NEW I THINK THE NEW
FRAMEWORK THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
LAID OUT WITH THE DIFFERENT
COLORS AND KIND OF GOING BACK
MAKES TOTAL SENSE AND WE SHOULD
PROBABLY STARTED THAT TWO
MONTHS AGO JUST SO THAT WE CAN
SEE. PROGRESS BUT EVERYBODY'S
COMMITTED AND WE'RE NOT WE'RE
NOT DONE WITH THIS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A LOT
MORE TO DO AND WE'LL GET BACK
THE CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE
THIS. LET ME JUST SAY THAT THIS
ALL HAS TO DO WITH MONEY MMHM
IT'S RESOURCES AND TO THE
CHALLENGES WERE LOOKING AT THE
CRYSTAL BALL TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAN DO. BETWEEN NOW AND IN
DECEMBER- WHICH ARE BUDGET
GOING TO LOOK LIKE. WHAT ARE
OUR RESOURCES GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AND HOW CAN WE USE THEM TO
LEVERAGE OTHER RESOURCES
WHETHER IT'S THE BANK OR THE
CREDIT UNIONS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
MONEY IS. IS CHEAP IF YOU CAN
BORROW IT. BUT NO ONE CAN RIGHT
SO HERE WHAT'S THE PERFECT
COMBINATION THERE'S A
COMMITMENT TO WORK I CAN TELL
YOU THAT RIGHT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE A MAN SHOULD JUST
KIND OF A FINAL COMMENT. AS AS
THE AUTHOR SAID THE CO AUTHOR.
IT'S ALL ABOUT MONEY. BUT THE
MONEY AVAILABLE TO. A WORKING
FAMILY ON A LIMITED INCOME.
STRETCHING TO RAISE RENT MONEY
EACH MONTH. IS DIFFERENT THAN
THE BURDEN. ON A LARGE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION. THAT IS
AN INTEREST GROUP THEY HAVE AN
INTEREST IN GETTING THEIR
MONEY- BUT THERE EXECUTIVES
MAKING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR. THEY'RE NOT
BEING ASKED TO FOR BEAR ON.
HUGE INCOMES. THERE IS SOME
RELATIVE. A HUGE RELATIVE
DIFFERENCE IN THE ABILITY TO
SHOULDER ON THE PAIN OF THIS SO
ARE BETTER ABLE TO FOUR BETTER
THAN OTHERS- SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ALL THE VOTING ON IT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK A
CINEMA IN THE OFFICE INDEED TO
AND THAT'S PART OF I THINK THE
EFFORT THAT'S BEEN MADE. OF
AGAIN WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO SEE
ANYTHING MORE COME OUT OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD
LOOK AT WHETHER THEY CAN BE
EXTENSIONS OF THE CARES ACTON.
ARMY IT'S JUST SO ON KNOWN WE
ARE LIVING IN UNCHARTED WATERS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT LEVEL OF
LEADERSHIP WE'RE GOING TO SEE.
THE STATE IS DOING ITS BEST TO
ALL FIFTY STATES HAVE FIFTY
DIFFERENT SETS OF RULES
COUNTIES HAVE. FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT SETS OF RULES IN THIS
IS. THIS A SITUATION WHERE WE
WOULD BE HARD PRESSED TO HAVE A
QUICK CANCER OR EIGHT A CLEAR
ANSWER SO I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT
THE EFFORTS GOING TO BE MADE.
THROUGHOUT AS THEY SHOULD BE
BECAUSE- AGAIN PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING AND- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I NOTICED THIS DOES
NOT. IN IN ANY WAY. EITHER
REDUCE THE OBLIGATION TO PAY
THE RNT THE OBLIGATIONS STILL
THERE IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN TO
PAY BACK RENT. OF THE
OBLIGATION BECOMES UP UP AS A
CREDIT. AND THE- TENANT IS
PROTECTED BECAUSE THAT DOES NOT
GET REPORTED TO THE CREDIT
AGENCIES. RIGHT BUT THE
OBLIGATION CONTINUES IT IS IT
IS NOT FORGIVEN AND BUT BUT THE
REALITY THE SITUATION IS HE YOU
KNOW AS WELL AS I DO THAT DEBTS
IN SMALL CLAIMS COURT NEVER GET
PAID. I MEAN THERE'S A WAY TO
BE ABLE TO TRY TO ENFORCE THEM
BUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT SO THE
CHALLENGE IS GOING TO BE BACK
BACK RENT AND EVER BEING ABLE
TO COLLECT IT. RIGHT NOW AND
THE CHALLENGE I THINK IS FOR
EVERYONE FOR US TO. NOT ONLY
GET BACK ON OUR FEET BUT TO BE
ABLE TO RECOVER. FULLY FROM
THIS OTHERS MUCH AHEAD OF US US
SENATOR- THE RISE SO I BELIEVE
YOU HAD A COMMENTER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- I WANNA THANK-
SENATOR BOB IDEA AT ALL AND
SHE'S BEEN WORKING REALLY
REALLY HARD ALONG WITH A-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CHIU I JUST
WANT TO DESCRIBE AND- CONNECT
THIS WITH WITH MY OWN DISTRICT.
MY DISTRICT IN LOS ANGELES HAS
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
RENTERS IN THE ENTIRE STATE.
SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT. OF THE
MEN WOMEN IN MY DISTRICT ARE
RENTERS. THE IMPACT OF THAT IS
GOING TO BE SEVERE. AND
OVERWHELMING. MANY OF THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE SOME WELL OFF
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT MOST OF THEM
ARE WORKING CLASS IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WE ALSO HAVE THE
HELP OF SOME OF THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS OVERCROWDING MEANING
MORE THAN OF A RATIONAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE PER ROOM OVERCROWDED.
THEY WORK AND ESSENTIAL JOBS
WHERE THEY ALSO ARE NOW FACING
CIRCLE BY YOUR NOSE THIS FOR
OUR REPRESENTING OUR
AGRICULTURE AND THE JOBS OF THE
FARMWORKERS TO. ESSENTIAL WORK
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND THESE
ARE THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY
LIVED IN. PART OF THE REALITY
WE'RE FACING HERE TODAY IS THAT
THERE WAS ALREADY AN EMERGENCY
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. THERE WAS
ALREADY AN EMERGENCY. THAT WE
WERE NOT SOLVING. THERE WAS AN
EMERGENCY AS FAR AS HOUSING
THERE WAS AN EMERGENCY AS FAR
AS HOMELESSNESS AND SO WE IT'S
NOT LIKE THIS JUST JUMPED OUT
AT US ALL OF A SUDDEN IT DID
BUT HAD WE NOT HAD THOSE
CONDITIONS BEFOREHAND I THINK
IT MIGHT OF YOU KNOW WHO KNOWS
MIGHT A LITTLE BIT MORE
MANAGEABLE. TENANTS DID NOT
WERE NOT STABLE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO PUT HERE
IN THE CONVERSATION AS WELL AND
I KNOW SOME OF US TRIED TO WORK
WITH THEM AS A WORKING GROUP
HOUSING WORKING GROUP WHILE WE
WERE TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS
AT THE SAME TIME TRYING TO
THINK MID TERM AND LONG TERM AS
FAR AS HOUSING BUT TENANTS
STABILIZATION IS AN EMERGENCY
BEFORE HAND AND IT'S EVEN MORE
OF AN EMERGENCY NOW. I HAD
SEVERAL BILLS ALONG WITH ALL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ABOUT RENT
RENTERS ABOUT THEM BEING ABLE
TO STAY IN THE HOMES ABOUT THEM
BEING ABLE TO STAY IN SPITE OF
THE GENTRIFICATION IN SPITE OF
THE PUSH OUT SO THAT OTHERS
COULDN'T MOVE IN AND. TAKE OVER
THEIR THEIR COMMUNITIES. SO THE-
OUT ECONOMIC INTEREST THEY ARE
OUTSIDE ECONOMIC INTERESTS FROM
THOSE WHO REALLY CARE ABOUT OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. IS GETTING HAS
GOTTEN IN THE WAY IT ALWAYS HAS
pBEEN THE ONE TO GET IN THE WAY
OF TRYING TO GET BETTER TENANT
PROTECTIONS. AND YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES. WHAT ARE
WE GONNA TAKE WAS WHERE WE- CAN
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. FOR THE
FACT THAT. THIS PROPOSAL
CHANGED FROM SOMETHING THAT WAS
MUCH MORE. IT WAS STILL A SHORT
TERM BUT IT CHANGED IN A MATTER
OF WHAT A WEEK. IN A MATTER OF%
A WEEK. SO I FIND MYSELF LIKE
THIS IS TERRIBLE WHY WE LET
THIS HAPPEN FROM A WEEK AGO TO
TODAY. WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
HAVE A GREATER POLITICAL WILL.
YOU KNOW MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE RENTERS MORE
THAN HALF. SO ARE WE HAVE TO
COME TO GRIPS WITH THIS ARE WE
GOING TO APPROACH THIS AND I
KNOW THERE'S AND I I'D LIKE TO
HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE SENATE
BYE BYE YET ABOUT THIS PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD. BECAUSE I CAN'T
COME BACK. IN JANUARY AND SAY
WELL HERE WE ARE AGAIN. SORRY
WE DIDN'T COME UP WITH
SOMETHING STRONGER TO PROTECT
YOU WELL WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
YOU ANOTHER TWO MONTHS BANDAID.
THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR
US IN CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE A
GREATER ABILITY WE HAVE THE
POWER TO BE ABLE TO DO MUCH
MORE MUCH DEEPER. THEIR
ORGANIZATION IN LOS ANGELES
CALL CHIRLA THAT WENT THROUGH-
I THINK IT TOOK A MONTH OR SIX
WEEKS SOMETHING- TO BE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE ONE TIME FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CHECKS. WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY ONE TIME FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CHECKS AND THEY
SAID THAT. ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
ONE OVERWHELMINGLY. THOSE
FAMILIES WERE CRYING ABOUT HOW
THEY NEEDED THAT CHECK TO HELP
THEM KEEP THEIR APARTMENT IN
SPITE OF THE FACT THAT WE HAD A
MORATORIUM. IN SPITE OF THAT.
THEY WERE SCARED TO DEATH AND
THAT ENTIRE FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CHECK WAS CAN BE GIVEN TO THE
LANDLORD AS A PLEASE TO LET
THEM STAY IN THOSE HOMES IN
THOSE APARTMENTS. THAT'S HOW
DESPERATE THEY- PUT ASIDE
WHETHER THEY HAVE PUT ON THE
TABLE THEY JUST WANT TO BE ABLE
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES CAN YOU
IMAGINE THEM FACING. BEING
HOMELESS SO. I'M BY NO. WELL I
HAVE TO HAVE A COMMITMENT
THAT'S MUCH MUCH DEEPER. MUCH
MUCH MORE COURAGEOUS ALL OF US
I'M CLEAN MYSELF MUCH MUCH MORE
COURAGEOUS ABOUT PUSHING FOR
THE A REAL SOLUTION AND I
INCLUDE IN THAT I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
HAS A LOT TO DO. WITH WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
HERE ON HERE ON THE GROUND AND
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT WE HAVE TO BE
READY. THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
CHANGE IN THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE TO BE
READY TO DEAL WITH THAT AND I
WOULD PROPOSE THAT WE SERIOUSLY
LOOK AT A SPECIAL SESSION WE
NEED ALL OF THE POWER OF US
TOGETHER TO SAY THIS IS A
PRIORITY. SO MAYBE CENTER CUT
BY YOUR YOU CAN. TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE IF YOU CAN I DON'T
KNOW. BECAUSE YOU'RE SO BUSY
DOING THIS WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE- IS HOW DO
YOU ENVISION OR HOW TO THE REST
OF. YOUR YOUR YOUR COLLEAGUES
AUTHORS ENVISION. HOW WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS FORWARD
BECAUSE- I WANT TO BE IN THE
SITUATION AGAIN IN A FEW MONTHS
WHY DON'T WE DO THIS. I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WHAT
ARE YOU. OH I'M SORRY CENTER
MELINDA'S YOU'RE HERE AND YOU
DO HAVE A QUESTION WOULD YOU
RESERVE THAT AGAIN FOCUSING
PRIMARILY ON THE BILL THAT TO.
THAT WE HAVE HUGE PROBLEMS NO
QUESTION BUT WITH RESPECT TO
THE ISSUES IN THE BILL US
SENATOR. I'M THE FIRST ONE I
WANT TO DO IS ASK A QUESTION OF
SENATOR CABALLERO- YOU SAID
THAT. THE CHALLENGE IS GOING TO
BE GETTING THAT BACK RENTS.
PAID TO THE LANDLORD AND I
WONDER IF YOU COULD JUST.
REFRESH MY MEMORY HOW IT HOW
EXACTLY THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- TO
THE CHAIR- THE THAT- DEAD DEAD
DEAD. WILL BECOME A SMALL
CLAIMS COURT DEBT. IN OTHER
WORDS YOU CAN COLLECTED IN
SMALL CLAIMS COURT THIS WILL
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LANDLORD NOT TO GO THROUGH A
SUPERIOR COURT CASE IN ITS ITS
LENGTHY. LIKELY TO COST A LOT
OF MONEY AND ALSO LIKELY TO BE
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED THERE ARE
OTHER PRIORITIES THE COURTS
HAVE BEEN OUT OF SESSION FOR AS
LONG AS WE WERE TO. SO IT WOULD
BECOME A DEBT PAYABLE A
COLLECTIBLE THROUGH SMALL
CLAIMS COURT ITSELF IT'S FAIRLY
EASY TO FILE THE PAPERWORK AND
TO GO AND IT PROVIDES AN
ALTERNATIVE FOR THE TEN IT IS
WELL. TO BE ABLE TO GO AND
DEFEND THEMSELVES OR SAY YEAH I
DO IT AND OR OR THE AMOUNT IS
DIFFERENT AND HERE'S WHAT I'LL-
AFTER ONCE I GET A JUDGMENT AND
THEY COLLECTED JUST LIKE ANY
ANY JUDGMENT ON THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO ASK. FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT WHETHER THE TEN TO TEN
AND IS WORKING OR NOT TO DO AT.
A CREDITOR ED JET THAT. I'M
DRAWING A BLANK ON THE WORD TO
BUT THE- THEY HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE- TENANT. AND TO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS AND USE THAT
INFORMATION TO DO TO GET IN A
COURT ORDER TO THEN- STARTED
CATCHING WAGES OR ANYTHING ELSE
THAT THEY MAKE. THAT THEY MAY
HAVE SO IT BECOMES A DEBT LIKE
ANY OTHER DEBT THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS THAT IT DOES NOT
GET REPORTED TO THE- CREDIT
REPORTING AGENCY SO THAT IT
DOESN'T. FUNDAMENTALLY HURT
THEIR THEIR OPPORTUNITY GET
LOANS AND- IN THE FUTURE HE
SAID THE DEBTOR'S EXAMINATION
LETTERHEADS AMINATION THAT'S
WHAT OKAY GREAT THANK YOU OKAY.
AND THEN- OR HOW HOW WILL THIS.
WORK IF YOU HAVE. AT TEN THAT
WOULD NOW BE PROTECT. UNDER
THIS BELT LET'S SAY. IN
ADDITION TO NOT. BEING ABLE TO
PAY THEIR RENT. AND THEY ARE
ALSO NOT COMPLYING WITH. THE
RULES AND THE NEIGHBORHOOD
WEATHER BACK TO NATURE WHERE
JUST SIMPLY YOU KNOW THEM. THE
ROLES OF TENANCY THE RESPECTED
OUR CONTRACTS SO LIKE SENATOR
BOARD JUST POINT OUT IF YOU'VE
GOT PEOPLE WHO WERE HAVING LOUD
PARTIES WHO ARE PARKING WHERE
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO YOU
KNOW JUST DOING ARE NOT BEING A
GOOD TENANT ARE THEY- THIS LAW
AND THEN- CAN PROTECT THAT TYPE
OF BEHAVIOR AS WELL NO IT DOES
NOT. IT DOESN'T IT DOES NOT
KNOW ANY IS A NORMAL- BASIS FOR
EVICTION OTHER THAN NON PAYMENT
OF RENT STILL APPLY SO IF YOU
HAD A TENANT WHO IS CAUSING
WASTE TO THE PROPERTY OR
CREATING NUISANCE. TO THE LEVEL
OF A TERM OF THE FOR INNOVATION.
THOSE VISIONS ARE STILL
APPROPRIATE. BUT EVEN IS THAT
ALSO. EVEN IF THEY HAVE
SUBMITTED THEIR LETTER SAYING
THAT THEY ARE UNABLE TO PAY THE
RENT DUE TO COME IN FOR IT
ABSOLUTELY. ABSOLUTELY OKAY IT
DOESN'T IT'S NOT AN EXCUSE.
OKAY I JUST WANTED TO SORT OF
MAKE SURE I WAS CLEAR ON THIS
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS
PROBABLY GOING TO CAUSE SOME
CONFUSION FOR LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS- I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
COUPLE COMMENTS- YOU KNOW I'VE
HEARD A LOT OF. OUR STATEMENTS
ABOUT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HASN'T DONE WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BE DOING THAT HASN'T BEEN
ENOUGH THERE HASN'T BEEN
ANYTHING I JUST. WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT IT. NUMBER ONE IF THE
GOVERNOR WOULD ALLOW MORE
SECTORS OF OUR INDUSTRY TO OPEN
UP PEOPLE TO GO BACK TO WORK
AND HAVE THE MONEY IN ORDER TO
PAY THE RENT AND HE'S NOT
ALLOWED THAT TO HAPPEN SO I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK.
IN THE MIRROR WHEN WE'RE
DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
WE ARE NOT WITHOUT FAULT I
THIS RESPECT OR AT LEAST THE
GOVERNOR IS IN MY EYES HE JUST
RELEASED. A NEW YOU KNOW NEW
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT FOR COUNTY
STEPPING UP AND PEOPLE CAN'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND THAT SO I THINK
THAT NEEDS TO BE TALKED ABOUT
AS WELL NUMBER TWO. IT YOU KNOW
THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA. IS EXTREMELY HIGH
THE COST OF BRENT AND
CALIFORNIA IS INCREDIBLY HIGH.
THAT IS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
FEDERAL GVERNMENT THAT HAS TO
DO WITH THE POLICY THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE. BY OUR
LEGISLATURE. IS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
GOVERNMENT SO AGAIN I SUGGEST
RATHER THAN. POINTING FINGER
SOLELY AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE TAKE A HARD LOOK
IN THE MIRROR AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR AS WELL- ALL
RIGHT. THIS THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE REALLY
ON PINS AND NEEDLES- FOR SURE
AND I WANNA. THANK CENTER
CAVIAR AND EVERYONE ELSE ON THE
BILL FOR TAKING THIS ISSUE HEAD
ON AND TRYING TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION. IN WHICH YOU KNOW YOU
CANNOT PLEASE EVERYONE IT IS
JUST IMPOSSIBLE- AND THANK YOU
FOR TAKING. THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS ON THIS BILL- AND I
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO MAKE MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
MELINDA'S I JUST WANT TO
RESPOND VERY BRIEFLY THAT TO
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER WE
SHOULD BE OPENING UP YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY A QUESTION OF HOW
MUCH WE VALUE HUMAN LIFE. BUT
WE'VE HAD TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS STOCK. TEN
THOUSAND MINUTES. TO AN
EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER OF PEOPLE-
THAT. BY MAY IF WE IF WE HAD
NOT. IF WE HAD NOT CLOSED THE
STATE. IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED IN NEW YORK.
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE DIED WITHIN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE-
OF COLD IT. WAS RUNNING RAMPANT
SO- I YOU KNOW I THINK WE'LL
ALL BE. MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKS ON THIS FOR A LONG
TIME AS TO. WHAT WE SHOULD AND
SHOULDN'T HAVE SHOULD NOT HAVE
DONE- AS FAR AS CALIFORNIA
BEING AN EXPENSIVE STATE IT IS
INDEED AN EXPENSIVE STATE IT'S
A BEAUTIFUL PLACE TO LIVE. AND
SO THE VALUE OF PROPERTY. A
SOMETHING A PRIVATE PROPERTY
RIGHTS THE VALUE PROPERTY IS
VERY EXPENSIVE- SO. A ONE COULD
ARGUE THAT THE COST OF
BUILDING. A IS MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN IT MIGHT BE BUT IT ALSO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR US HAVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE WE HAVE HERE
SO. THERE ARE CERTAINLY ISSUES
THAT WE CAN. AGREE ON AN AGREE
TO DISAGREE ON BUT THERE ARE
CERTAIN FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES THAT
I THINK WE'RE ADDRESSING HERE-
THAT THIS BILL TRIES TO ADDRESS
THAT ARE REFLECTIVE OF A BIGGER
PROBLEM. ASSOCIATED WITH A
PANDEMIC FOR WHICH WE STILL TO
THE STATE. HAVE VERY LITTLE
TREATMENT- WE HAVE NO CURE AND
WE HAVE NO VACCINE. AND THAT'S
PART OF THE NKNOWN THAT I
THINK WE'RE ALL TO DEAL WITH SO.
MOVE THE BILL I APPRECIATE
THAT- THAT DISCUSSION AND WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE
CAL SKI I'M SORRY. SORRY CENTER
Y. CASKEY. ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION HERE- SEEING. BOB.
HE'S OFFICES ARE USING
FURNITURE EVERYTHING. WE RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE A MOTION- WE'RE
GOING TO- ASK SENATOR CAFIERO
TO CLOSE AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE SURE CENTER MELINDA'S
DID YOU WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
YOUR HAND WAS UP AND THEN IT
WENT DOWN. YOU'RE ALL SET. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR CAMBIADO
YOU MAY CLOSE. MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
HAVE THIS ROBUST DISCUSSION-
THAT DISCUSSION WAS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE MANY MANY MANY
HOURS OF CONVERSATIONS THAT WE
HAD AMONG OURSELVES TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW WE WERE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET TO YES THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION S
WORK. THIS IS A NEGOTIATION
BETWEEN THE SENATE THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND
WHILE- IN ARBIL SB FOURTEEN TEN
WE THOUGHT THE STATE OUGHT TO
BE PUTTING UP SOME MONEY. TO BE
ABLE TO. HELP TO- CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES WHETHER IT WAS-
THROUGH A TAX CREDIT OR WHETHER
IT WAS TO LEVERAGE. MONIES THAT
BANKS HAD- WE JUST COULDN'T GET
THERE IN THE IN THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE HAD IT AND
FRANKLY. ARE PART OF THE REASON
IS BECAUSE OF THE UNKNOWNS THE
UNKNOWNS YOU KNOW WHEN IS THIS
PANDEMIC GOING TO GOING TO A-
OR- IS IT ACTUALLY GOING TO
START. GOING DOWN UP WE JUST
HAVEN'T SEEN IT AND I WERE.
BACK IN APRIL WHEN THEY SAID WE
THINK THE NUMBERS ARE GOING TO
GO UP GO DOWN IN JUNE AND WHEN
THAT WHEN THE SUMMERS HERE AND
I THOUGHT JUNE ALL MY GOSH
THAT'S SO FAR AWAY AND HERE WE
ARE IN ITS SEPTEMBER. IN TWO
DAYS AND SO- ALL OUR PROJECT
PROJECTIONS AND PREDICTIONS FOR
THIS VIRUS HAVE HAVE GONE OUT
THE WINDOW AND SO. THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO GET US THROUGH THE
YEAR. SO THAT WE CAN MAN. SO
AS- THE AS WERE OUT OF SESSION
WE CAN LOOK AT. TAKING PROBABLY
VERY LIMITED STATE RESOURCES.
AND USING THEM TO LEVERAGE
OTHER RESOURCES AND HOPEFULLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
COME IN AS A PARTNER AND HELP
US TO MAKE- SOME SOME CHOICES
AYE AYE. IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
FINISHING THE BUDGET. IN THE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING WE'RE SPENDING LOTS OF
MONEY ON A LOT OF THINGS SO WE
KNOW WHEN WE YOU TALK ABOUT
WILL YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
CENTER DRIVE SO WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT IF WE HAVE THE WILL.
TO PUT MONEY INTO HOUSING AND
TO BE TWO THINGS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO CHANGE THE
REALITY FOR PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND- WHETHER IT'S
HOMELESSNESS OR PEOPLE LIVING
IN SIGNIFICANTLY OVERCROWDED
SITUATIONS WHICH IS A SEPARATE
ISSUE- SO THE QUESTION HERE IS-
THIS ISN'T A PERFECT BILL THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE DON'T GET
EVICTED. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO PAY THE RENT AND THE
REALLY GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
DATA THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS IS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THEIR
LANDLORDS AND MAKING PAYMENTS
EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT PAYING THE
ENTIRE PAY RENT DUE AND I
EXPECT THAT THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE BECAUSE PEOPLE FEEL A
REAL COMMITMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE HOUSING IS SECURE.
AND SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
SETS UP A FRAMEWORK FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO TELL LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS THIS IS HOW YOUR HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO- MANAGE THAT
THE SITUATION AND WE DON'T WANT
TO EVICTING PEOPLE AND WE WANT
TENANTS TO PAY AT LEAST 25% OF
THE RENT AND IF YOU'RE MAKING
MORE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY MORE UNLESS YOU CAN PROVE
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN. IMPACTED BY
THE CORONAVIRUS FINANCIALLY
AND- AND HOPEFULLY WILL KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF COURT THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE AND IT WILL WORK
THE COMMITMENT IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO STAY AT THE TABLE AND
WE'LL WORK THROUGH THE THROUGH
THE END FROM TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT PIECES WE CAN PUT
TOGETHER FOR THE NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MONNING THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BATUM
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE SENATORS
COULD PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CAN.
JACKSON HI. JACKSON HI BORJAS.
PURCHASE WHAT IS THE NUMBER
THIS BILL. THREE ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT. REGIS R. S. B. A. B.
SORRY AB. FOUR ZERO TWO ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT WHATEVER IT IS HI
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT
REGENERATED THERE WE GO YES I
DID I ALL I DID US IN I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB THREE ZERO EIGHT
EIGHT SINCE I NEED ONE MORE
TIME TO REVIEW THIS I'M GOING
TO ABSTAIN FOR NOW MELINDA'S
MONNING AYE STERN. UMBERG I AM
BURKE I Y. CASKEY HI AYE CASKEY
AYE. FOUR FIVE ALL RIGHT THE
EVENT IS ZERO SEVEN TWO ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH BANTA GOOD LUCK WITH THIS
AND WITH ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WE ARE TURNED. WHAT.